I think he wants you takes very special
he's always like doing things his own
way where are you guys playing oh boy
you know if we could afford it there's a
private song even what I want for Jake
I know we've always said we're not those
parents but Afghan afford to be the
numbers are ridiculous
you have to remember everybody wants
diversity well I'm gonna talk a little
about his gender expansive play you want
him to be somewhere he can thrive right
you really think it's weird he does like
to play dress-up that's not news yeah he
likes fairy tales well maybe that's not
the most critical thing worth mentioning
he asked why boys can't wear skirts I
didn't want to send him off to
kindergarten labeled he's only four what
if he starts thinking there's something
wrong with him let go right in a few
weeks we'll visit some new schools and
you should just be yourself and that's
all that matters okay there's no big
deal at all
is a constant friend I'd like to show
you something there were one or two
incidents in class and love is a hand to
kindergarten it's so hard for a child
you know which is why there's nothing
you have some choices to make here maybe
we should bring in to see something
maybe the problem is that we started
pushing him into this role you're the
one buying him every princess DVD you
can get your hands on and this freaking
out when people start to notice is it
any wonder he's confused
you try so hard to protect them but it's
never gonna be easy to really see people
especially like the ones we love is for
one two three
[Music]
you